5 45 your Monday morning was driving you  crazy got a viewer email about a bumpy  freeway ride  Kevin rice on the Northbound 95 515 just  after the Charleston exit there are  asphalt patches in the far left lane  that aren't at the same level as the  concrete causing vehicles to bump up and  down on my commute most everyone jumps  into the middle Lane while hardly anyone  uses the far left lanes maddening it's  almost like having the lane closed endot  needs to get out there and raise the  patches so that they are at grade  Kevin I will be forwarding your note to  the Nevada Department of Transportation  but my guess is the response is going to  involve the new project there to improve  the 95 515 access to and from Charleston  that is going to include work on the  freeway itself I'll have the official  response in a future report thanks for  writing buckle up drive carefully and  please put down that phone you can join  the driving you crazy conversation at  traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com